Rolanda is with us in Virginia hi
Rolanda how are you hi I'm doing great
how about yourself better than I deserve
what's up um yes sir um I just got about
five hundred thousand dollars and life
insurance from the death of my husband
um yes and it's just me and my son and
I'm a stay-at-home mom I'm just trying
to figure out what to do next how old
was he
I mean was 27 what happened um he just
got into a bad place I'm so sorry
oh my goodness and how old's your baby
q4o baby I'm sorry how long ago was this
six eight weeks three months three
months yeah okay oh okay do you have
family around you in in próxima close
proximity I'm not yet I'm actually
moving back with family and a couple
days cool
where's that I'm back in Texas okay and
how wise is your family with money very
wise okay that's good news okay and
you're gonna just stay with mom for a
little while while you ki why are you
getting where you can breathe again yes
sir okay because it takes a while just
to breathe again
I mean you and I just met and I'm having
trouble breathing with this story Wow
okay so here is my preference how old
are you I'm 26
okay so you're the age of my kids and
I've got grandbabies your grandbaby your
baby's age okay so if you were my
daughter here's what I would tell you to
do okay mm-hmm
do as little as possible with this money
until you can breathe try not to make
big decisions while you're in the fog
because humans hurt when stuff like this
happens unless you're a psychopath
you're hurting and so give yourself some
room to hurt and don't try to make big
decisions while you can't breathe is
that logical to you there's no there's
no race for you to become a financial
wizard okay so if you just take this
money and put it in a savings account
and don't touch it that wouldn't make me
mad at all for six months now I don't
know if you can do that or not I mean
you may have to do a few things with
money here or there I mean you may have
some funeral expenses you may have some
moving expenses you may have a few
things from debts or something that you
want to clear up but try not to make
major decisions and certainly don't
start using this money on a spending
spree okay
so just pretend like it's not there I
think I think I'm hearing that your mom
and dad can take care of you for a
little while and give you a place to
live and some food right yes sir okay
now and you know so write a few checks
and clean up the details don't just let
stuff sit right I mean going to do
business properly but you do not need to
become an investment wizard you do not
need to think about buying a house you
do not need to think about spending
money going back to school for six
months because you've got it covered mom
and dad got you covered and you won't
have to touch this money am I correct
about that yes there okay all right give
yourself a little room okay and and the
fog will start to lift the thing about
grief is the further from the event you
get the the clearer your mind gets
there'll always be a place that hurts
because you love and you'll always look
at your baby and you'll always see him
and that'll always be there but it'll be
but your brain will just work better
over time
and I just want you to you know I don't
want to expect you to be fully
functional you wouldn't you'd be weird
if you were fully functional to that
does that make sense
so give yourself some grace to just cry
and just just because it kind of comes
at you in waves doesn't it yeah okay so
take your time
then when the fog starts to lift you can
call me back or what I'm gonna do is put
you on hold and Madison is going to hook
you up with maybe one of our not maybe
we will we're gonna hook you up with one
of our financial coaches so that in a
few weeks no rush you can sit down with
them it'll be no charge to you we do not
charge widows okay thank you and this is
a coach that's been trained by us they
don't work for us but they've been
trained by us they're in Texas
they'll sit down with you as a our gift
to you and begin to help you kind of
comb through some ideas of what you can
do if you were to invest this money or
use a little of it to buy a house and
then invest the rest that would be wise
all of that would be good the thing you
don't want to do is get into grief
spending which is spending so spending
so I feel better and I look up and I've
got a five hundred thousand dollar set
of regret because I burn through this
money but I'm thinking that your mom and
dad will help you a little bit with that
because you were raised in a family that
doesn't do that kind of thing and
they'll be there to kind of hold you
accountable lovingly is that okay I was
the church exactly on a great church as
well to wrap their arms around you and
give you a good hug yeah and so just
take your time there's no rush it's okay
if you do virtually nothing for six
months it'd be okay if you did virtually
nothing for a year you're going to be
okay because you got the rest of your
life to goof around with this five
hundred thousand dollars okay and
there's a lot of stuff you can do with
it college it fun for the baby you can
invest some of it you could pay cash for
a little house there in Texas or you
know and you know have some money left
to invest and that kind of stuff you can
make some decisions like that later
please don't make those now is it does
that does that sound like it rings truth
to you yes okay I'm so sorry
thank you I'll put you I'll put
John Holden Madison will pick up and
will get get you hooked up with one of
our coaches as our gift and we'll walk
with you through this